well i'm speaking today with dr stephen
hicks
who's a professor of philosophy
at
in the department of philosophy at
rockford university in illinois and
professor hicks has written a book that
i found he's written several books
but he's written one
in particular that i want to talk to him
about today called explaining
post-modernism skepticism and socialism
from rousseau to foucault which was
published fair why is it a fair while
ago now in 2004 but i think has become
even more pertinent and relevant today
and i have talked a lot to my viewers
about your book and so
let's talk about post-modernism and its
relationship with new marxism that's and
so maybe you could tell
our
viewers here a little bit more about
yourself and how you got interested in
this
i finished a graduate school in
philosophy in the early 90s
originally from canada born in toronto
uh at that point uh pittsburgh and
indiana had the two strongest philosophy
of science and logic programs that's
what i was interested in at the time so
upon a professor recommendation i ended
up at indiana and it worked out very
nicely for me
so most of my graduate work was actually
in epistemology philosophy of science
logic some cognitive science issues as
well so
a lot of the epistemological and
philosophical
linguistic issues that come up in
post-modernism
the groundwork so to speak was laid for
that
when i finished grad school i started
teaching full-time uh came to rockford
university he was teaching in an honors
program
and the way that program worked it was
essentially a great books program so
that was like getting a second education
wonderfully
but uh the way it was done was uh each
course was taught by two professors to
our honors students and so the
professors would be from different
departments so paired with
literature professors
history professors and so on
and this is now the middle 90s i started
to
hear about
thinkers i not read i kind of heard
about them but now i was reading them
more closely
and finding that uh in history and
literature and sociology and anthro
uh names like dairy dog buco and the
others were
if not omnipresent were huge names so i
realized i had
of a gap in my education to fill so i
started reading
deeply in them
my education in some ways was
broad in the history of philosophy but
narrow
at the graduate school level and i focus
mostly on annual american philosophy so
my understanding of the continental
traditions
was quite limited but uh by the time i
got to the end of the
90s
i realized there was something
significant going on coming out of
continental philosophy
and that's uh where the book right came
out and when when you say significant do
you mean
what do you mean by that you mean
intellectually do you mean socially
politically there's lots of different
variants of
at that point intellectually this is
still the 1990s so post-modernism was
not yet outside of say art
a a cultural force but it was strongly
an intellectual force in that
at that point uh young phds coming out
of sociology
uh literary criticism
some
sub-disciplines in the law if you're
getting phds in the law
historiography and so on and certainly
in uh
departments in philosophy still
dominated by continental traditional
philosophy
that almost all of them are primarily
being schooled in
what we now call post-modern thinkers so
the leading gurus are people like gary
dah
uh leotard from whom we get the the
label postmodern condition
foucault right uh and and
maybe you the
maybe you could walk us through what you
learned because people are
unfamiliar i mean you had you had you
were advanced in your education
including in philosophy and still
um
recognized your ignorance say with
regards to post-modern thinking and so
that's obviously a condition that's
shared by a very large number of people
and
post-modernism is one of those words
like existentialism that covers an awful
lot of territory and so maybe we could
zero in on exactly what that means and
and who these thinkers were daredesco
and leotard and and what you learned
about them okay yeah fair enough
well all of the
thinkers you just named
they think broadly they think
strategically and they do have a very
strong historical perspective
on their disciplines and at the same
time they are trying to assess
where they think we are culturally
politically socially
and all of them are making a very
dramatic claim
that to some extent or in some way
modernism has either ended
or it has reached its major
right or all of the kind of the
pathologies and negative traits
within the modern world are reaching a
culmination
uh in their generation
and so it's time for us to both
recognize right that modernism has come
to an end that we need some sort of new
intellectual framework a post-modern
like framework okay and the modernism
that they're criticizing what how would
you carry that's it that's enlightenment
values that's that's scientific
rationalism how would you characterize
it exactly right yeah all of those would
be uh right elements of it so and of
course there are some discipline
specific uh uh differences so literature
people and philosophy people and
historians will use modernism slightly
differently
but the idea
core is that if you look at the
pre-modern world right essentially
uh the world of the middle ages saying
but that was itself broken up by a
series of revolutions the renaissance
reformation counter reformation early
scientific revolutions and all of this
is going on
in uh historically short chunks of time
1500s and 1600s
and so if you look at the both the
intellectual world and the social world
uh comparing say the 1400s with the
1700s
culturally and intellectually you're in
a different universe right at that point
so the features then of the of the
modern world uh and now i'm going to use
my philosophical labels here
are that we are now
naturalistic right in our thinking that
we're no longer
primarily supernaturalistic but in our
thinking so we might still be open to
the idea that there's a god or some sort
of supernatural dimension like the way
deists are but first and foremost we're
taking the natural world as a more or
less self-contained
self-governing world that operates
according to cause and effect and we're
going to study it in its terms we're not
seeing the natural world as
a derivative right of a higher world or
that everything that happens in the
natural world
is uh is part of god's plan and we read
omens and so forth into everything so
metaphysically then there's been a
revolution and we're naturalistic
epistemologically uh in terms of
knowledge there also has been a a
revolution uh how do we know the
important truths how to require the
beliefs that we're fundamentally going
to commit our lives to but by the time
we become moderns we
take experience seriously personal
experience
we do that more rigorously and we're
developing scientific method uh the way
of organizing the data
we're taking logic and all of the
sophisticated tools of rationality uh
and developing those uh increasingly and
so our position then is either you know
something because you can experience it
and verify it right for yourself
or we've done the really hard work of
scientific method
uh and as a result of what comes out of
that that's what we can call knowledge
or our best approximation to that okay
so also revolutionary let me just say
one more thing because
right the prior intellectual framework
right was much more uh intellectually
authoritarian right in the in its
framework right so you would accept uh
in the catholic tradition the authority
of the church right and who are you to
question the authority of the church and
who are you to mount empirical rational
arguments right against right the
authority of the church or you take the
authority of scripture right or you
accept on faith that you've had a
mystical revelation of some sort so in
all of those cases you have non-rational
right epistemologies that are dominating
intellectual discourse that is all by
and large swept away right in the modern
world okay so so
prior to the emergence of the modern
world we'll say
people are dominated essentially by
their willingness to adhere to a shared
tradition and that shared tradition is
somewhat tyrannically enforced but
there's no real alternative in terms of
epistemology let's say and then
as the modern world emerges
people discover the technologies of
science and the
the value of rigorously applied method
and the comparison of shared experiences
and that makes us technological
technologically powerful and in a new
way and philosophically different from
what we were before
yes the shared tradition phrase that
that you added there that's an important
one so i would say in the early modern
world there's not necessarily a
skepticism about a shared tradition so
students there would be an acceptance of
shared traditions but the idea is that
you would not uncritically right accept
your tradition but you will accept the
tradition but only after you've fought
it through and made your own
independence okay okay so so you're
elevated to the status of someone who's
capable of taking a stance with regards
to the to the tradition and assessing
its presence
okay so there's an elevation of the
individual and the critical intellect
along with the with the elaboration of
the scientific method okay so then then
we might note perhaps that
that's a tremendously effective
transformation although maybe it leads
in a somewhat nihilistic direction
metaphysically we can leave that to the
side but it's a very very successful
revolution because by the time at least
the beginning of the 20th century comes
along there's this staggering
and of course before that the industrial
revolution there's this staggering
transformation of technology and and and
technological and conceptual power and
then a stunning increase in the standard
of living and that starts in about 1890
to really
to move exponentially in the 1890s or at
least to get to the really
well really steep part of the exit
exponential curve okay so that seems to
be going well so what is it that the
postmodernists are objecting to
precisely
well by the time just on those two
issues uh
the the metaphysical naturalism
and then the uh the elevation of kind of
a critical
empiricism and a belief that we can
through science and
even not necessarily as science but
social scientists and so on come to
understand
powerful general principles about
humanity and social systems
uh those two revolutions both are then
subjected to counter attacks
uh and again uh
what happens
in this case is there was a revolution
uh
probably by the time we get to 1800 the
height of the enlightenment there are
the beginnings of more powerful
skeptical traditions that that come to
be developed so the thinkers are
starting to say things like well you
know if a scientific method at root is
based on the evidence of the senses
right we uh we observe the natural world
that's our first point of contact
uh and then on the basis of that we form
abstractions and we put those abstract
actions into into a propositions and
then we take those propositions and put
them in networks that we call theories
and so on so we start to
critically examine each of the elements
of scientific method
and over time
weaknesses in the existing accounts of
how all of those rational operations
work come to be teased out and
philosophy then starts to go down a more
skeptical path
so if for example you uh take perception
uh as fundamental that's our uh you know
the individual subjects first point of
contact with the natural world
then you have to immediately deal with
issues of uh
perceptual illusions
or the possibility that people will have
hallucinations or
that the way you report your perceptual
experience is at odds
with how i report my like perceptual
experience so we have all of that also
tell me if i've got this right so
with the with the dawning of the
empirical age let's say there's this
this idea that you can derive valid
information from sense data especially
if you contrast that sense data
rigorously without of others okay so
that's sort of the foundation for the
scientific method in some sense but then
i think this is with immanuel kant
there's an objection to that which is
that while you can't make the
presupposition that that sense data
enters your your cognitive apparatus
your apparatus of understanding without
a prior restructuring
and it seems to me that that's where the
post-modernists really go after the
modernists it's that given that you have
to have a very complex perceptual
structure that modern people might say
was instantiated as a consequence of
biological evolution you can't make the
case that what you're receiving from the
external world is something like pure
information it's always subject to to
some
very difficult to delimit degree
to
interpretation and and you then you also
have to take into account the fact of
that a priory structure and what it
might mean for your concepts of of
objective reality and that's kant i
think if i've got that right
right well the postmoderns will use both
of those strategies the uh the
anti-empiricist strategy and the
anti-rationalist strategy and what's
important about kant right is that kant
is integrating right both of those
anti-strategies so in the generations
before kant
the
the the skeptical arguments about
perception right directed against the
empiricists the empiricists want to say
everything is based on
observational data but then if you don't
have good answers about uh
hallucinations and relativity and
delusions right and so forth then it
seems like your your structure your
intellectual structure whatever it comes
to be if it's all based on
probabilistic or possibly faulty
perceptual data then the whole thing is
a is a tottering brightness
and by the time we get to kant uh the
empiricist tradition
is uh largely unable
uh to respond to those kinds of
objections and so kant is recognizing
and saying all right we've been trying
now for a couple of centuries we haven't
been able to do so successfully uh we're
not going to be able to do so
now you also know nicely right emphasize
that uh one of the other the other
responses have been on the rationalist
side
which is to say well uh no you don't
start with pure empirical data instead
that we do have perhaps some innate a
priori structures uh built into the
human mind how they got there maybe
they're put there by god maybe they're
put there naturalistically right or
whatever
uh but what enables us to have
legitimate knowledge right is that our
empirical data comes in and it is
filtered and structured by
these pre-existing red cognitive
structures as well
now the problem with that side right of
the of the line uh and this is also well
worked out by the time we get to the
content is to say well if you're
starting with inbuilt cognitive
structures
and everything that comes in so to speak
goes through the structuring machine and
you're aware of the outputs right those
that's what's presented to your mind
well how do you know that those inbuilt
structures like have anything to do with
the way reality actually is out there it
seems like then what you are stuck with
is the end result of a subjective
processing
and there is no way for you so to speak
to jump outside of your head right to
compare the end result with the way the
world actually is independently of how
your mind has structured the awareness
so once again you're struck stuck rather
in a rather subjective place and again
the importance of kant here is then he's
also looking at this more rationalist
tradition and he's saying well look
again we've been trying now for a couple
of centuries to work these things out
you know from descartes to spinoza
leibniz and the others and rationalism
also right has reached a dead end so
we're not going to be able to uh to do
so
so kant is in effect standing at the end
of these two traditions and saying you
know uh the skeptics have it right on
both sides both the empiricist and the
rationalist tradition fail
there is no way for us to objectively
come to know an external reality we're
stuck in some sort of deep subjectivism
okay so i don't know now whether to talk
a little bit about the american
pragmatic approach to that or whether to
maybe we should go ahead and continue
our discussion of post-modernists
because they're developing these claims
absolutely and some of the
post-modernists do describe themselves
as neo-pragmatists like richard rorty
for example so yes that's exactly a
direction that's worth going
okay okay so
my
my understanding of that if i was going
to defend the modernist tradition let's
say
i would say that
we we have instantiated within us an a
priori perceptual structure that's a
consequence of millions billions of
years for that matter of biological
evolution
and it it has it has emerged in tandem
with continual correction of its
presuppositions by by the selection
process but it's it's still subject to
error because
we have a very limited viewpoint as
specific individuals and we can
we can
not only are we limited but we also make
you might say moral errors and i'll get
back to that that cloud our judgment
and so in an attempt to
expand our purview and rectify those
errors we do two things we test our
hypothesis practically against the world
which is to say we say here's a theory
of reality we act it out if the theory
of reality is sufficiently correct when
we act it out we get what we want
and then that's sufficient proof for the
validity of the theory it's not absolute
proof but it's sufficient proof and then
the other thing we do and i think this
is being paid attention to much less
except by thinkers such as piaget
is that we
further constrain our presumptions
presuppositions about reality with the
necessity of constructing theories that
are also acceptable to people around us
so they have to be
in integratable within the
the
currently existing social contract and
they have to be functionally
appropriate in the
external world and that's a nice set of
constraints and it seems to me that that
at least in some part
goes a long ways to
answering the objections to the
to the limits of the scientific methods
that have been discussed that were
discussed
and that you just discussed that have
been discussed historically and that you
just summarized okay
all right uh i'm sympathetic to uh much
of what you went through in fact a five
point right uh response right to the
kinds of arguments that have been uh
played out but you're actually putting
me in the position then of uh defending
the post-modern tradition
right about how it would
undercut right each of those components
right so
if you take for example uh evolutionary
epistemology and you give a nice sketch
of uh one standard evolutionary
epistemological reference you say okay
maybe we have these infill a priori
structures but we can rely upon them
because uh here we are standing at the
long end of uh you know
hundreds of thousands or millions of
years of evolution and they would not
have survived or enabled us to survive
had they not served some sort of
reliable cognitive role
representing like the the way the world
works
now what the the postmodern uh this is
actually too early for the postmoderns
although the postmoderns will agree with
this is to say that all of that
uh kind of begs the question right in a
very deep way against the kind of
skeptical objections that we're raising
because in order to
make
that paragraph long description right of
what evolutionary epistemology is
what i have to do is take for granted
basic assumptions certain truth right
about the world
that for example
there is
an external world right that we are
biological creatures right that we have
inbuilt structures that those
restructures are
uh evolutionarily responsive and
conditioned by changing forces like and
so forth
and if you take those uh assumptions
right to be true
then as a consequence or as a conclusion
you can infer that therefore
the
uh intellectual products that come out
of our cognitive processing are reliable
right in some way but
where did you get those four premises
from how do you know right that there
was an external world how do you know
that we are biological creatures
how do you know or that evolution right
is true with all of the historical
knowledge it's necessary
to reach the conclusion that evolution
is true all of that presupposes
that we have legitimate cognitive
methods to come to understand the world
but our having legitimate cognitive
processes to understand the world that's
exactly what we are arguing about in the
first place and you can't just assume
that right for them the sake of coming
up with some premises that are then in
turn going to validate those cognitive
processes
so something like that right they will
say is there's a there's a big circle a
circular reasoning problem
that that evolutionary epistemology
finds itself trapped in now
i think there are some responses to that
and this is just the first back and
forth right on that particular debate
but that is the kind of response that
that would be there
no uh the third and fourth of keeping
track uh accurately is to say that we
also have uh constraints
right with respect to uh to ourselves
uh
that
if we have a certain set of hypotheses
or certain better theories
and we're testing them out
we will accept those that give us what
we want right so or what i want right so
to speak right
and i'm also necessarily in a social
situation so i need to do is check my
results against the uh the results of
others peer review
experiment replication right and so
forth
in the same household yes absolutely
right more prosodically right uh
sharing our frameworks right with each
other right and so on and so if so to
speak uh and this is the more pragmatist
orientation
if we then say we have a theory right or
a set of principles or guidelines or
whatever and they do enable me
successfully to navigate the world right
to get what i want or they do enable me
to navigate my social world to get us
what we want
uh then they're reliable true or some
sort of
uh success label epistemologically that
we're going to do okay so okay so let me
ask you a question about that this is a
place where i got augered in very badly
with uh with sam harris when we were
discussing metaphysical presumptions so
you know
and and i'm confused about this i would
say to some degree conceptually because
i'm i'm i'm a scientist and certainly
operate most of the time under the
presupposition of an independent
objective world but then i also have
some difficulty with the idea that
objective truth it's that it's objective
truth within which all other truths are
nested and that's something that sam and
and the people that he represents in
some sense are very
dead set on insisting now it seems to me
though that the crux of the matter is
something like the method of proof
and this strikes me is very important
because
my theory is correct
enough if when i implement it i get what
i want is not the same as they claim my
theory is true because it's in
accordance with some independently
existing objective world i mean both of
those things could exist at the same
time but i think the more
appropriate claim to make with regards
to human knowledge is something like its
biological functionality which is that
your knowledge is of sufficient accuracy
which is about the best you can hope for
because of your fundamental ignorance if
when you implement it it reliably
produces the results that are
commensurate say with your continued
existence now it seems to me that that's
a reasonable claim from a darwinian
perspective and it also seems to me that
it's very much in keeping with the
claims of the american pragmatists
and i mean it's not like they were
radical postmodernists because they
weren't but they were trying to solve
this problem to some degree of of our
fundamental ignorance and our our
inability to be certain about the nature
of the reality that surrounds us
yes
okay let's uh set aside uh sam harris's
uh version of this and focus on the the
pragmatist right tradition here so no
you're absolutely right uh william james
john dewey right in the others late 19th
century early 20th century
they are coming
a century after the kantian revolution
uh after hegelianism
uh uh and so forth and so they are very
much trying to
solve this problem the one way and this
is going to be a very american right
sort of things to say look
maybe the problem with philosophy is
that we have been to
intellectualizing
right cognition right that we're not
just you know disembodied brains or
disembodied minds
that are trying to kind of contemplate
abstract truths in some other realm
maybe what we need to do is understand
right the mind and cognition as a
naturalistic process
and that the purpose of knowledge is not
to come up with these pure and beautiful
truths that are going to be kind of
museum pieces that we will admire
but rather the purpose of knowledge is
functional
the purpose of knowledge is to guide
action
uh and so they will then hearken back to
the earlier
dayconian tradition the knowledge
knowledge is not an end in itself
because they can put it uh francis bacon
uh knowledge is power right and
by its fruits right so to speak right
well you know it's uh
you know this work
and so what we then should do is to see
that the test of true right is not right
whether it
uh meets purely intellectual standards
of logic right and mathematics
but rather when we put it to practice
and when we act upon it
we actually get
good results or we get the results we
want or i get the results i want and it
can come in more individualistic form or
more socialized right because then we
can get on with things too right let's
find our ignorance in some sense so
there's two things that are being
packaged here right one is to say
uh that knowledge right is functional
and that part i think is important and i
think it's a very nice
correction right that the pragmatists
are it's not original with them but they
are re-emphasizing it in the 19th
century and
knowledge needs to be pushed to the test
uh and uh it's its ability to to enable
us to uh to to be pragmatic right so to
speak in the real world is
is its test
yeah and then there's a code
there's a code to that as well and i
think this is relevant to thomas kuhn's
discussion of scientific revolutions
because kuhn is often read as
positing a sequence of in some sense
discontinuous revolutions but if you if
you and and and that the conceptual
structure that characterized one
uh epoch let's say like the medieval
epoch was
so totally
different in its presuppositions from
the conceptions that characterize the
next epoch that you can't even mediate
between them in some sense and now the
reason i'm bringing this up is because
kuhn is at least read as hypothesizing
that there's not any necessary progress
when you make leaps from one conceptual
system to another but if you take this
pragmatic approach the one that we've
been outlining it seems to me that you
can say
well it's something like this
your conceptions of the world are more
tool-like than objective truth-like and
tools can have a greater or lesser range
of convenience and so if you come up
with a really good tool which would also
be something that would look objectively
true generally speaking then that's
something that you can use in almost
every situation and it will never fail
you and i would think of something like
newtonian physics in that regard or even
more particularly quantum mechanics
because it's never failed us and so
it seems to me the pragmatic approach in
some sense allows you to have your cake
and eat it too you can posit a hierarchy
of truths moving towards an absolute
truth even but also retain your belief
in your own ignorance and not have to
beat the drum too hard about the like
well eternal accuracy of your objective
presuppositions
okay
again i'm sympathetic i think with about
80 percent of that but let me put my
skeptical
uh hat back on and say how the
postmoderns or the critics of pragmatism
are the release of first generation
pragmatism will respond to that so if we
then say right all of these uh
cognitive result and rephrase that
okay
so if we're going to assess all of our
cognitive uh results or cognitive
hypotheses in terms of
uh their workability right or they're
getting what i want or what we want
well then the big question we have to
turn to is to say well how do we judge
whether something works
they say
uh
that it's good because i get what i want
or we get what we want
well what is a want right where do these
wants come from
and why should we accept wants
and desires
and uh achieving certain goals as our
bottom line so to speak
right okay so you can that's right so
you can start to question the framework
the validity of the framework within
which you're constructing the answer
that's right and at this point we're
leaving epistemology right neutrally so
to speak and moving into normative
issues
and so the whole status of
normative uh goals ends and then the
means that are going to enable us to
reach reach rather those ends comes into
play so
if i want to say the most important
thing is that i i'll put it very boldly
here
i get what i want
and i'm going to assess
intellectual structures and beliefs and
hypotheses in terms of do they give me
what i want well that already sounds
like a fairly uh
normatively subjectivistic standpoint
why should you take your wants as having
some sort of high status that everything
has to be evaluated in terms of
uh and then
philosophically then we say well where
do wants come from of course there's a
long anthropological and psychological
set of literature
uh here what's the relationship of our
wants are they
based in biological drives are they
instinctual are they acquired are they
intellectual
do they have any relationship to our
rational capacities when i'm acting
should i act on my desires and my wants
right and so forth
so there's that whole tradition and we
have to have a sophisticated theory
right about how all of that is going to
work if we're going to say
we'll solve all of these cognitive
epistemological issues in terms of
wants or the satisfaction of desires or
the achievement of goals the way
pragmatists want us to do
and again uh it's fairly easy to uh to
imagine what the skeptical arguments are
going to be right if it's a matter of
what i want well
isn't science supposed to be about
coming up with general truths uh or or
maybe even universal crudes and if we're
immediately just going to devolve it to
whatever individuals want well then
we're going to be in a fairly scattered
right
okay so that also opens up a good point
for a segway into the potential link
between
neo-marxism let's say and post-modernism
because maybe you could say once you've
opened the door to an admission that you
can criticize the
the idea of want
as a social construct let's say which is
one of the things that you intimated not
the only thing obviously
then
you open the door to also making the
claim that
that
that social construct that governs the
wants that governs the truth can be
governed by power relationships
something like that and then by unfair
power relationships exactly so you can
spin off down that aisle which
and and that's the other thing i really
want to talk to you about is because
on the one hand the post-modernists are
following this intellectual tradition of
the critique of of western thinking
which is exactly in some sense what
philosophy should be doing but in
another way they seem simultaneously to
be introducing almost by sleight of hand
a kind of social critique that has its
origin more in political revolution and
class-based theory and they do that
they do that under the guise of pure
philosophy in some sense but with the
intent and motivation of something like
justifying the social revolution or
continuing the marxist the marxist
analysis of power differential it can go
both ways yes right it is possible to
follow the road that we've just been
going down to say well you know if it's
a matter about uh
you know what works for you then that
immediately starts to sound too
relativistic and subject to this yeah we
don't have
an explanation or an answer rather to
all the weirdos who want to do strange
things because that's what they want to
do so we might introduce as a corrective
right a socializing right of the process
right so we might then say no it's not
so much what you want as an individual
but rather what we want and we need to
achieve some sort of a consensus here so
this is
a slightly cartoon version here but the
difference between william james who was
more individualistic and john dewey in
the next generation who collectivizes
things but a little bit more
so then we have a corrective on all of
the individual weirdos who knows what
their desires and goals right are going
to be right but then we of course we
just confront the same problem there as
soon as we start doing anthropology
because then if we say well if we
relativize it to the social group when
we start looking at different social
groups obviously different social groups
have dramatically different wants and
needs and desires and they've evolved
very different traditions
and if it's a matter of saying what's
true is what works for the group
uh there is then no sort of uber group
right or or highest group of all groups
that uh has status over all of the
others right and if you do and this is
the second point that you said right
exactly right
uh then you're saying well no no this
group's uh norms and its goals are
better than that groups goals or norms
right okay then you're into uh uh what
the critics are going to call
imperialism right of the of the of the
inappropriate form
right so that leaves us
that leaves us with our current
political situation in some sense which
is because that's been it's been that
idea has been taken to
what to
that's a logical conclusion and that
logical conclusion has now been
instantiated to a large degree as a as
an intellectual and political activist
movement i would say right sure
absolutely so it can start as an
intellectual movement that we're trying
to do some hardcore epistemology right
and we go through the empiricists and
the rationalists in the contin
revolution and the pragmatists right now
we're in the second generation
pragmatism where we've relativized it to
various kinds of groups and then we're
just stuck in a kind of right group
relativism and then the operational
principle socially then is going to be
that each group so to speak should stick
to itself and not think that it can
impose its ideas and its norms on any
any other group right all groups right
so to speak are
are equal yeah well they have an equal
claim to they have an equal claim to
their formulation of the truth like the
problem with the with the post-modern
conjunction with neo-marxism to me seems
to be the idea the acceptance of idea
that there's an intrinsic moral claim
by the dispossessed
to the to the obtaining of status and
that actually constitutes a higher moral
calling in and of itself so they're
swallowing a moral claim that in making
it universal in some sense at the same
time they criticize the idea of say
general narratives or universal moral
claims
okay now that's also right that's that's
the other way rather than starting with
epistemology right and ending up and
getting to a kind of cultural relativism
right you can start of course committed
to a certain normative framework right
or a certain ideological framework
uh
as marxism is where you're very critical
right of one of those traditions and
then the cultural relativism can be
right a part of that that you use to
criticize the tradition right internal
right so to speak
now then uh
we're explicitly into
uh not kind of meta ethics and asking
where do we get our ethical principles
off the ground or where do they come
from in the first place but kind of a
robust
normative ethics where
people have committed commitments rather
to fairly strong
ethical principles and ethical ideals
and this is where the debate between say
nietzsche and and marx becomes relevant
uh and this is a late 19th century right
debate so suppose we say
as both the marxists who and the
nietzscheans rightfully do so you know
there is no truth in any objective sense
like we said all we have is subjectivity
and relativity right of the various
sorts
and we have different individuals and
different uh
groups and they are in uh antagonistic
conflict relations right with each other
and that means there's not really going
to be any uh you know rational and civil
resolution of these discussions with
each other instead it all comes down to
power
uh
yeah that's the strange sleight of hand
claim there too because why it has to
come down to powers again that seems to
introduce the
necessary need
okay yeah all right that's another thing
let's set that aside just for a moment
okay
uh but then we say okay so we have power
right and one thing that we can say is
while we don't think any one individual
any one group has a better
objective claim to truth or better
ideals
it is not in the leicester clas case
that some individuals and groups have
more power right than others
and so then we have to make our
allegiance clear right in this unequal
power struggle are we on the side of
those who have more power or are we on
the side of those who have less power
and that's where we get venetian and
marxian right forth in the road right so
the nichians following nietzsche will
say look
uh it's all about power uh you know
we've been driving on some crude
evolutionary thinking here
it's only the exercise of power right by
the stronger the fitter the healthier
and so forth
are are willing to impose their power on
the weaker and use them for their own
ends that we as individuals and groups
are going to make any sort of progress
right toward the next best thing
whatever that is
so in the power struggle you know there
is no objective
morality and objective truth uh we just
throw our lot in with the stronger but
the richer with the more powerful they
say whatever it is that they do in order
to advance themselves that's the
normative best that we can do
and of course there's a long kind of
aristocratic tradition right uh in
normative thinking that one can draw
onto or to support that
and the marxist marxist rather of course
it was on the other side of that
equation right where their
sympathies right initially are going to
be to say you know in any power struggle
our kind of a priori
commitment so it should always be to the
weaker right for those on the losing end
or the history those who suffer right
and so forth and it's always the the bad
rich and powerful people who are
oppressing and harming them
and so we throw a lot in with the weaker
and we're willing to use power whatever
amount of power we have on behalf of the
weaker
and then right
then we're just into what i think of as
a you know the major false alternative
that really has driven much of 20th
century intellectual life are you
right right well and that okay so now we
can get to the crux of the matter here
to some degree because to even engage in
that argument means to accept the a
priori position which which you've made
quite rationally compelling let's say
that it's power it's power because
there's no other way of differentiating
between the claims of different groups
it's power that's the determining issue
but yeah that that's something i really
have a problem with and i think it's
it's of crucial importance because first
of all i think there's a big difference
between power
there's a difference between power and
authority and competence those are all
not the same thing because
you might be willing to cede greater
status to me in some domains if there
are things i can do that you value that
you can't do and that's not power
exactly power seems to be more that i'm
willing to use force to impose my
interpretation of the world to get my
wants fulfilled on you
and it seems to me that where the
marxists make a huge mistake not that
the nichians aren't making mistakes as
well but where the marxists make a huge
mistake is that they fail to properly
differentiate between hierarchies of
interpretation that are predicated on
tyrannical power and hierarchies of
authority competence and mutual consent
because those and
the other issue that they fail to
contend with and i believe this is a
form of willful blindness is that
it isn't obviously the case that every
society is set up equally to only
fulfill the desires of the people who
are in principle situated at the
pinnacles of the hierarchies i actually
don't think that that's fundamentally
characteristic of the western tradition
because it has a very strong emphasis
weirdly enough and this is how i think
it extracts itself out of the social
the socialized
the conundrum that accepting a a
socialized version of truth presents to
you the the west does two things it says
we have a social contract that
constrains our views of the world and
our actions in it but that social
contract is also simultaneously
subordinate to the idea of the
sovereignty of each individual
and so
the social contract then is bound to
serve the needs of each individual not
any privileged set of individuals
although sometimes it works out that way
and i don't believe that the
postmodernists have contended with that
properly with their with their criticism
of logocentrism for example which was
something that characterized darada
because i think that that because i it
doesn't it never has seemed to me that
what you had with stalinist russia
and the marxist view of the world
and what you had on the side of the west
was merely a
matter of a difference of opinion
between two equally valid socialized
modes of interpreting the world you know
there's something wrong about
there's something more to the view of
the west
than
what's in battle what's embodied in the
conflict between say capitalism and
socialism because it could have just
been a matter of of argumentation and
opinion but i think that that's that's
faulty and
i i thought this way in part because of
piaget
you know because piaget was interested
in what the intrinsic constraints were
on a social contract
and he said and he was trying to address
this issue of the insufficiency of want
as a
as a as a as a tool to justify your
claims to true
and that's when he introduced the idea
of the equilibrated state so if you're
sophisticated
you have to
put forward your want and then meet it
in a way that
will meet it today and tomorrow and next
month and next year and in a decade so
you have to
iterate yourself across time
and you have to take all of the
iterations of yourself across time with
with some degree of seriousness
and then you also have to do the same
thing as you extend yourself out into
the social community so it has to be
what's good for me now and
repetitively into the future in a manner
that's simultaneously good for you now
and simultaneously into the future and
that starts to become and he thought
about that as the playable game
something like that the voluntarily
playable game and there's something deep
about that because it includes the idea
of iteration you know iterated
interpretations into the equation which
strikes me as like of crucial importance
okay yes
again i think my account about six very
interesting subtopics right built into
that
and uh the latter part a very nice uh
statement i think of a kind of an
enlightenment humanism where we're going
to take power seriously but we're going
to
constrain power in a way that respects
the individual and simultaneously
enables individuals to form mutually
beneficial right social networks across
time and so on
uh
and i'm very sympathetic right to uh to
that overall right construction
uh
that comes out of then the first part
which is a taxonomy right that you're
offering about the nature of power
and that taxonomy does differ
significantly from both the marxist
right and and the nichian one
now
what i'd say is you know
i think it's better to take power right
more
neutrally
um
so there's a continuity with what the
physicists do my understanding there is
the power is just the
ability to get work done
so it's uh it's uh you know we can put
it in tool and functionality right
language
right power is what gets you from a to b
right right which is also that i love
that description because it fits very
nicely in with the narrative
conceptualization of being because
narratives seem to be descriptions of
something like how to get from point a
to point b right but it also doesn't say
anything about b
right in the status of b
how we choose
where we should be going right what our
ends are right or what our goals are
going so in that sense
power is normatively neutral it's a
means to an end
uh and that means when we start to try
to evaluate
right the uses of power
we're going to be evaluating power in
terms of the ends toward which it is put
right
if i can end with that preposition here
so now
then we say okay well power comes in all
kinds of forms right we you know we're
quite happy to say yours intellectual
power right that's the ability to use
our minds to to address and solve
certain problems there's muscular power
the ability to move physical objects
there's a social power you know uh
people respect you and are are willing
to spend time with you and divert
resources to you
voluntarily and so forth
uh there's military power political
power and so we can have a whole
set of subspecies of power and what they
all have then in common is
uh in each of those domains there are
goals and having the power enables you
to achieve your goals in
those domains right and we shouldn't
fall prey to the illusion that there's
necessarily any
like what would you call it unifying
matrix that makes all those different
forms of power importantly similar
except for the terminology you know i
mean and this is another thing that
bothers me about the both the nietzsche
and the marxist marxist view is that
there's this proclivity to collapse
these multiple modes of power into power
itself and that's not reasonable because
it it's reasonable to note that many of
the forms of power that you just
described contend against one another
rather than mutually fortifying one
another it's like it's like the balance
of power in a in a polity like the
american equality yeah i think that's a
that's a deep point that you're making
uh i think both the marxists and the
nietzscheans do
end up collapsing power
into a unitary type
all right that's a mistake
uh but it's a mistake only if you
deny right as both the marxist and the
nietzscheans do
that there is a deep individuality right
about the world
so if you think by contrast right about
the kind of
individual human rights respecting
enlightenment vision right that you're
articulating and that i agree with right
as well
but
normatively that wants to devolve social
power to the individual and leave
individuals with a great deal of
self-responsibility and control over
their own domain right so to speak
the idea then is that if we're going to
form
social relationships or any sort of
social interaction it has to be kind of
mutually respecting that i have to
respect your control over your domain
and you respect my control over my
domain
but we agree to share domains right so
to speak voluntarily right to a certain
point it all it also means and this is a
place where i think the post-modernists
are really open to
you might say conceptual assault is that
you know
in order to have that freedom devolve
upon the individual in that manner it
also means that the individual has to
take responsibility for acting as a
locus of power in the world actual
responsibility and cannot conceive of
themselves or act in a manner that only
makes them an avatar of a social
movement and i think that part of the
preferred anti-individualism of the
radical left is precisely predicated on
that refusal to take responsibility and
i think that's also reflected in the
fact that by temperament they're low in
trait conscientiousness right so it's
deep it's it's not merely an opinion
it's an expression of something that's
even deeper than opinion okay that yeah
that great locus of responsibility locus
of power locust control
you're right that the far left right in
the marxist and neo-marxist forum does
deny that but you also find that in far
right yes
in general right and so this is a bit of
cartoon right to intellectual history
right but then if you try to trace it to
the marxists on the left and the
nichians on the right both of them do
deny that individuals are locus loca
rather of responsibility both of them in
their views of human nature have
strongly deterministic views right what
we call an individual right according to
both of them right is just a vehicle
through which
right uh outside forces are flowing
right so to speak right well you can
also see that in some sense as a
perverse consequence of the scientific
revolution because you still see this
among modern scientists it's like okay
what are the causal forces that regulate
human behavior okay there's two primary
sources nature slash biology and culture
right so it so it's the crude nature
versus nurture debate right being played
out through them yes
right so and that's then that there's in
my my opinion and i've derived this
conclusion from studying mythology
mostly is that there's a missing third
element there which is whatever the act
of force whatever it is that constitutes
the active force of individual
consciousness right
that grounds right self-responsibility
and
being an independent right initiator
right of power instead of merely a
responder to other power forces right or
a vehicle through which those other
power forces operate
right so yeah the individualism
that is built into enlightenment
humanism you start to see it developing
in renaissance humanism right is to take
seriously right the notion that
individuals have
some measure some significant measure of
control
over their thoughts over their actions
to shape their own characters to shape
their own destinies and that is
fundamental right to one's moral dignity
as a human being
and so that is going to be uh that view
rather of human nature built into the
ethics uh fundamentally and then all of
social relationships have to be
respectful of that individuality and
then consequently when we start to turn
to political theory and we stop talk
about very heavy-duty uses of power such
as the police and the military uh we
want to have serious constraints on
government power to make sure that we
are respecting the individual
sovereignty well
okay so here's something perverse too
that that that
emerges as a consequence of something
you pointed out earlier in the
conversation you know you mentioned that
when modernism emerged out of
medievalism that two things happen and
one was the elaboration of the
conceptual frames that enabled us to
deal with the external world but the
other was the elevation of the
individual to the status of valid critic
predicated on the idea that there was
something actually valid about
individual experience as such
now the problem there as far as i can
tell and maybe this is part of the
reason we're in this conundrum is that
the the elaboration of the objective
scientific viewpoint led us left us with
the idea that it was either nature or
nurture that was the source of human
motive power
but the the missing element there is
well if that's the case then why grant
to the individual to begin with the role
of independent social critic like on
what grounds do you and it's like the
it's like the residual it's like a
residual belief in something like the
autonomy of the soul but you can't just
sneak in and not justify without without
without problems like the ones that we
have now yeah no that's uh that's well
put and i think it's it's fair to say
that we still are in the infancy of the
the psychological sciences you can speak
to this better than i can but as someone
in philosophy i think we're still at the
at the beginnings
and we are still in the grip of early
and crude
versions uh accrued scientific
understandings of how cause and effect
operates
and so what we are starting with is very
mechanical
uh uh understandings and we can
understand how people then are pushed
around by biological forces
we can understand to some extent how
they're pushed around by external
physical and mechanical forces
but we do not yet have a sophisticated
enough understanding of the human brain
the human mind human psychology
to understand how
a volitional consciousness can be a
causal force
of causal power in the world right so
that's perfectly well put so in this i
do a detailed analysis that some of the
people who watch me are familiar with of
this movie pinocchio
and pinocchio is got a very classic
mythological structure and it basically
introduces three elements of being so
there's the element of being that's
associated with gepetto and also the
evil tyrannical forces that are kind of
patriarchal in nature and that's sort of
the conceptualization of society a
benevolent element and a malevolent
element say and then there's the
introduction of this other causal factor
and it's personified in the form of the
blue fairy and the blue fairy is a
manifestation of mother nature and she
animates pinocchio so gepetto creates
him
and then sets up a wish for his
independence and then nature appears in
the guise of the blue fairy and and
grants that wish so you have culture and
nature conspiring to produce
um a puppet that could in fact
disentangle itself from its strings but
the movie insists and he does this on
profound mythological grounds that the
puppet itself has a causal role to play
in its own um what would you call its
own capacity to transcend the
deterministic change that it's been that
that have the deterministic processes
that have given rise to it but that also
enslaved it and you know in in all of
our profound narratives i would say and
this is part of the way that they differ
from the standard scientific account
there's always that third element
there's always the autonomous individual
who is in some sense
you know lifting himself up by his own
bootstraps and and i don't think it's a
problem that science
is unable to account for that but it's a
very big problem with scientists who are
unable to account for that deny that it
exists because they can't explain it
that becomes extraordinarily dangerous
right yeah uh all right once you stop
looking uh you stop trying right then
you're you're left with an impoverished
account so you know in a way there's a
kind of hubris right built into the
skepticism right that says you know i
know that this is a problem that we just
can't solve and so i'm not going to try
try any more
well and there's a there's a there's a
performative contradiction as well which
is much worth pointing out because
on the one hand
the scientists might well claim
as far as i'm concerned from an
epistemological person perspective the
only two causal forces are nature and
culture but then i'll go about my
actions in the normative world
as an existential being acting in the
world and i will swallow wholeheartedly
the proposition that each individual is
responsible for his own actions because
that's how i constantly interact with
everyone in the world and i get very
irritated if they violate that principle
yeah
right so yeah how you uh live so to
speak with your skepticism or with your
relativism in a way that doesn't snarl
you in
tensions and contradictions that's a
that's a hard project itself right well
it does it does seem to me that it i
think it's reasonable to point out that
it's not possible to find a person who
acts as if he or anyone else is
biologically or culturally determined
we just don't behave that way in the
real world we act as if we're
responsible for our own actions and and
the consequences of those actions right
so then we have a tension between what
our intellectual theories right are
telling us
and what our kind of empirical data
right is telling us that we don't yet
have a way to put those two together
uh and then what you as an individual do
in response to that tension between
theory and practice
that's a whole other
can of things to explore right to yeah
to back up
to our discussion about power um
it's interesting that
the way our discussion right up to that
point then integrates right three things
we started talking about truth
uh and then we started talking about
goals and
normative ends right in ideals
and then
we
talk about power so there we've got
already the big three right truth
uh ideals right and power
and our discussion about truth right
took us into epistemological issues
right in philosophy
our discussion about ideals where it
takes us into ethics and meta ethics
issues again also in philosophy
our discussion of power right takes us
then into issues about human nature
which traditionally like a branch of
philosophy and now lots of
sub-disciplines are doing so we already
have
to have a theory of epistemology and a
theory of human nature
a theory of ethics
and we in some sense try to integrate
those and post-modernism is going to be
an integration right of certain views
that develop in philosophical traditions
in all three of those areas
so maybe one way to put it is this if
you if you contrast it to
again taking the enlightenment as our
touchstone
uh
since we're both you know fans of the
enlightenment
we say all right we're fine with with
power right knowledge is power right and
we want to
empower the individual right we want to
eliminate slavery and empower people we
want to eliminate
old-fashioned sexism and empower right
women
so power is yeah we actually want to
remove arbitrary and unnecessary
impediments to the expression of proper
power that's right so there are
illegitimate uses of power
that are stopping and disempowering
right people so it's the the
double-edged sword
uh and as long as power is properly
directed or properly located
right then we are confident by and large
people individually and socially will
use their power to
put together useful lives build
uh
successful economies and societies right
and so forth so there's actually a very
optimistic right overall assessment
about uh about about power
but power right is then structured as a
means to an end
and we want to empower people
cognitively teach them how to read
teach them how to think
right so that they themselves can
uh understand the truth and discover new
truths right so
power leads to truth but we also then
right want people to uh be free
to uh to uh to uh to act on the basis of
their their power
uh because then we think that if people
are respected as individual agents
they're going to be happier
uh and so they'll achieve good goals and
they will mute work out together fair
will uh agreements and and deals uh kind
of justice right well the society will
get better and better
uh and so forth so
power is in the service of just
social relations and power is in the
service of true
yeah okay so
that's a great that's a great um
that's a great
justification say for the enlightenment
viewpoint and it seems i don't want to
stop you from pursuing that but it also
seems to me that
to the degree that that's
true
a valid description of the enlightenment
aims and to the degree that that's
actually manifested itself in reality in
the state in the current state of human
affairs that it's
perhaps unwise of us to allow our
marxist or our nietzsche and
presuppositions to
take a take too careless to swing at
that foundation given that it's actually
absolutely right that's why
the enlightenment articulation right
power is good if it's in the service of
truth
right or power is good if it's in the
service of justice that you were fine
and we're optimistic enough about human
beings cognitively and morally that we
think empowering them giving them lots
of freedoms is going to increase the net
stock of truth and it's going to
increase the net stock of justice so
that entire enlightenment package is
precisely what the counter enlightenment
attacks and attacks very fundamentally
so that by the time we get two to three
generations later to the generations of
marx and nietzsche it has been hollowed
out
so on the epistemological side right we
don't believe right that there is such a
thing as true right anymore
so it's not the case that power is in
the search of truth because we don't
believe that human beings are capable
right of getting any sort of objective
truth anymore so we're just left with
power
and also on the normative side we don't
believe in justice right anymore we
don't believe that any sort of normative
principles or ethical ideals can be
objectively grounded and so then once
again maybe we're left with subjective
desires right and so forth yeah but
we're just left again with power so okay
power in the service of truth power in
the service of justice that goes away
all we are left with is power
okay so sure then we could say we could
mount a psychoanalytic critique of that
set of objections because i could say
okay
here's some reasons
let let's assume that you're doing
something simple
and
let's assume you're doing something
simple and easy instead of complicated
and difficult
with your objections and so here's the
simple and easy explanation
you
want to dispense with the idea of
justice and truth because that lightens
your existential load because now
there's nothing difficult and noble that
you have to strive for and you want to
reduce everything to power because that
justifies your use of power in the
pursuit of your immediate
in pursuit of those immediate goals that
you no longer even have to justify
because you don't have to make reference
to any higher standards of say justice
or truth
and so i would say
that's a deep
impulsive and resentful nihilism that's
manifesting itself as a glorious
intellectual critique now i
understanding as well that there is
the history of genuine intellectual
critique that you'd be laying out which
is not trivial but those things have to
be differentiated you know
it's certainly not reasonable either for
those who claim that all there is is
power that they're not themselves
motivated equally by that power sure
so in one way all right what you can
always say in effect philosophy is uh
autobiographical in many cases that
philosophers will
put their pronouncements in third-person
form right or in generalized form but if
you always put it down to power or sorry
first-person formulations it can be
profoundly self-revelatory right so if
you say for example
human beings are
scum i think you have some sort of a
pessimistic assessment of the human
condition
uh well built into that then is the idea
that i right if i first personally i am
scum that's right you're really doing is
a is a uh is a first person confession
and
it's always been an illegitimate move to
exempt yourself right from the from the
general principle
everything just is to come back to our
more likely topic your power relations
and
people imposing their agendas on other
people
then what you're saying is well my
fundamental commitment is power and i
just want to impose my agenda on other
people so i do think you're right right
that it can go both ways it can of
course be
that you have people who for whatever
reason have a predisposition
to
nihilistic
uh amoral power seeking
and they when they become adults and
intellectual they latch on to theories
uh that indulge them enable them to
rationalize their
predispositions uh and so in many cases
yeah a lot of i think post-modernism in
some of its manifestations is
disingenuous right in that form that
people don't necessarily buy into the
post-modern philosophical framework but
rather in kind of pragmatic form
uh post-modernism as a set of tools is
useful
for them to
advance their own personal and social
agendas right whatever those happen to
be
because they find that
okay so let's switch a little bit let's
switch over into that a little bit i
mean i've i i found our discussion for
what it's worth i found our discussion
extremely useful
on the philosophical end but now i would
like to make it a bit more personal so
now you if you don't mind you've written
this book
and it's a fairly um
punchy let's say critique of
post-modernism and its alliance with
neo-marxism and and you've done
a careful job of laying out the
historical development of that
of both of those movements and their
alliance
um
what what was your motivation for doing
that and
what
do you what have you experienced
one as a consequence of writing the book
and two
as a consequence of a professor who's in
the midst of a
of an academic society that's basically
running on post-modern principles
yeah that's a good uh trio of questions
there well my my motivation uh for
writing the book was uh
motivations plural
uh one is an intellectual exercise uh
here was a movement
that
was complex many philosophical and
cultural strands right coming together
and uh i enjoy intellectual history very
much so it was a pleasure right for me
to uh to read back into the histories
and to tease out all of the lines of
developments and how things were
packaged and repackaged
uh
so that the post-modern synthesis right
as it came together in the
uh the kind of the second third of the
20th century right came uh came into
being
uh so kind of as a purely intellectual
historical enterprise i found that that
that fulfilling
uh partly also this was
1990s late 1990s it's end of the cold
war
uh one of the things i had done not
professionally but just out of personal
interest was
read a lot of political philosophy read
a lot about the cold war
and the the intellectual developments
and call it political developments that
had gone on there so i had a very good
i'd say amateur working knowledge before
i started researching the book
about uh kind of the history of marxism
and the history of
the cold war geopolitics
and so one of the big questions then on
everyone's mind of course in the 1990s
with the fall of the soviet union the
end of the cold war is
what's going to happen next right so
whether it's the new geopolitical
alignment going to be
but then from my academic position the
big question inside the intellectual
world is
since far-left politics had been so
uh prominent
and that for generations right
intellectuals inside the academic world
have largely given the benefit of the
doubt
too far leftist experiments uh even
going out of their way to be fellow
travelers right and so forth
uh
by the time you get to the end of the
cold war basically everybody except for
a few
true believers is
rethinking right so what does this mean
for
uh not necessarily left politics more
broadly but certainly for far left right
politics
uh
and so even the far leftist of the
leftists right are recognizing that
they're going to have to come up with
some sort of a new strategy
in order to remain intellectually
respectable
and some sort of a new
strategy in order to become uh
culturally and politically feasible
so i did have a
a kind of a cultural political interest
in
what the thinking was on the far left
about
what they're going to do now that
the soviet union has collapsed and the
whole world is shifting
more toward market liberalism or to some
sort of third way like centrism yeah and
now that all the corpses have floated up
on the beach right yes so you have a
huge that amount of empirical data
uh that you have to confront
and uh uh i think this is certainly
going to be part of the post-modern
package but there's a lot of
denial of the relevance of empiricism
uh a lot of denial of the the relevance
of logic and social scientific
statistical methods of aggregating that
data and reaching a moment of
conclusions on the basis of that so we
can understand a temptation on the part
of a lot of people to
to find
psychological devices that will enable
them to deny the gulag and the various
other horrible things right so also by
the time
the facts are
are stacked enough viciously again when
the facts as even you would have
construed them are stacking up viciously
in contradiction to your theory it's
time to mount an all-out assault on what
constitutes a fact okay that's one
strategy and that's again one of the
sub-strategies i think that post-modern
post-modernism will use right so
if you then have philosophers and social
scientists and people who are up to
speed in their epistemology
who are telling you well you know there
are just you know different narratives
that are out there
and there are no such things as
objective facts and logic does not
necessarily point us in one direction
there are poly logics or or multiple
frameworks then uh if you have right one
framework that says no there are
objective facts uh and the logic is all
going against your your version of
political idealism
it's going to be very tempting for you
to say well i can just dismiss that as
just one narrative way of constructing
the historical facts i can come up with
a different narrative that softens or
denies right altogether and certainly uh
some of the bad faith post-modernists do
go down that road like very much
so in part that was my uh my motivation
right for for writing the book right and
apart i did feel that i was in
a good position intellectually right to
do so because
my my phd work had been in
in that logic philosophy of science and
epistemology so i was up to speed on
the entire
history of uh
of epistemology from the modern world on
through
things or the way things were in the 80s
and early 1990s
so i was reading the same people uh that
rory had and i have to say i learned an
enormous amount from from reading
richard rorty he's first rate even
though i end up disagreeing
fundamentally with him about everything
uh
huco's phd also was in philosophy he
also had a phd in psychology
dairy daw another philosophy phd leotard
another philosophy phd
so uh not necessarily put myself on the
same stature right intellectually but uh
all of us so to speak are first-rate
educated in epistemology so i know where
they're coming from and where all of
that is going
at the same time uh my uh my
undergraduate and uh their master's
degree at guelph just down the road from
you
uh in history of philosophy so
i had a long-standing passion for how
arguments and movements develop over
time
uh so i i thought i had it was in a good
position to see how
post-modernism had evolved out of
various other earlier movements that
have developed over time
and i am enough of a political animal to
be interested in political philosophy
and i believe that abstract
philosophical theory when it puts it
gets put into practice makes life and
death practical differences
so the stakes are high
uh so i was motivated then to put it all
together how does the history and the
philosophy and the politics all come
together right in postmodernism so
so i wrote the book now uh
yeah how it has affected me personally
in uh in academic life well
let me see i
in one way i think i was fortunate
that i i had tenure by the time the book
was published
and
my university is by and large a tolerant
case we have some
some issues here but by and large my my
colleagues are
reasonable decent people
and
so i was able to get
tenure on the strength of my
my teaching abilities and my uh my
publication
um so it wasn't uh that i was going to
lose my job right over this
but uh of course there is there is blow
back i did have difficulty getting the
book published right in the first place
i should finish writing the book by the
year 2000
i had taken a sabbatical from 1999 to
2000 i wrote the book then
but i was not able to get the book
published until 2004
and uh the reason for that was
a number of
desk rejections you know the editor just
sends a form letter back i've got a few
of those but more seriously what
happened three times possibly four times
i don't remember exactly now was it
would get past the uh the editor at the
press
and then it would be sent out to two or
three reviewers
and in each case what happened was i
would get split and polarized split
reviews right one would come back and
say
you know this is a really good book you
know he's done his homework it's a good
argument it's a fresh argument don't
necessarily agree with all of it but
this really ought to be out there right
as a book
and then the other review or the other
two reviews on the other side would be
uh equally savaging but this is a
terrible book or he
doesn't know his history of philosophy
he's butchered just that or the other
thing and i strongly recommend that you
don't right publish this book
and then almost always in that situation
the uh the editor just said no
so it wasn't until
2000 and i guess late 2003
uh early 2004
uh scholar g which was in a small press
working out of arizona
took the book on and uh
i'm happy to say that after it was
published it's been in print
consistently but since then
yeah so remarkable that's remarkable
yeah so i'm very happy let alone an
academic book yeah
yeah and then multiple translations and
those continue so
so so i'm happy about that now uh let's
say the the scholarly responses have
been
from
um
moderate liberals or kind of traditional
i don't want to use the word necessarily
traditional but
rational naturalistic liberal right
thinkers uh conservatives and
libertarians the reviews have all been
strong and strongly positive
i've not received any formal reviews
from any of the uh the post-modern
or or far-left journals
um so i'm not sure right what that means
but there is a at least some level of
unwillingness to engage right with well
it might be a sign of respect
well there is one sign of respect that
comes out and that is that every let's
say once a year so probably a dozen
times since the book has been published
i've been asked by the editor of a of a
postmodern or close fellow travel or
critical theory type of journal to be a
second reviewer right on one of their
articles so
i'm in their rolodex right so to speak
uh to use the old-fashioned label as
when they are actually looking for
someone who's likely to give a
an objective but critical respect uh
perspective on some article that's been
submitted to the journal
once in a while my my name floats up and
they'll send it out to me so i'll just
do the standard thing of reading it and
giving my
my professional opinion of it
so i think they are aware of me but
there hasn't really been any direct
intellectual engagement which is
kind of sad
yeah so so now when you when you set
yourself up to write the book were you
thinking of writing a critique of
post-modernism or or were you thinking
of conducting an exploration of
post-modernism well
right now i'm working on the critique
but the the book ends
uh i don't want to say abruptly because
it did set out the purpose that it does
but it doesn't end with the door open
right
to say how then do we respond to uh this
this dead end of counter enlightenment
thought right in post-modernism
obviously we're at a point culturally
where
the meaning of post-modernism has now
you know it's infected the academy and
we see problems there but it's also left
the academy and so thoughtful people
outside the academy are seeing the
results
and so the big question is you know what
what do we do next so
so i am actively working on the sequel
to uh to explaining post-modernism now
and i did go back and forth uh in the
writing of it my my first purpose was to
write a straight diagnosis and
intellectual history of post-modernism
and uh that's where i that's where i
ended up leaving it because uh in one
sense this is a bit artificial but i i
really like 200 page books
it's uh it's kind of long enough for you
to get into a subject deeply enough
and to make a good pointed integrated
argument and then stop
and so i realized if i wrote the sequel
then
it would be a 400 page book and i
thought it was more important to get
this self-contained intellectual history
of post-modernism out there so
i i brought things to uh i think a
logical conclusion right where i did end
of the book and and now i'm working on
that on the next
what's the next one called
uh it just has a
working title or something it changes
right every uh every few months right or
or so
sometimes i think about it the the fate
of the enlightenment or something to do
with neo enlightenment
uh
right or
it won't be this but post-post-modernism
or after post-modernism
uh
yeah well we've been struggling with
terminology as well the problem that
i've been talking about with such things
right so and it's a very hard right
thing to do because it's uh
as we've seen
philosophically right post-modernism is
multi-dimensional like it's a it's a
metaphysical critique it's a normative
critique it's a political critique it's
an epistemological right set of views
and so the alternative then also has to
be integrated philosophically there has
to be an entire philosophical package
and so
what uh what label is going to capture
all of that
and at the same time make a connection
to post-modernism
and i also uh
i'm basically an optimistic positive guy
so i want something that uh yeah that
has a as a positive way forward yeah
that's right yeah well sorry
i think that's making a better place
right right exactly exactly so look i
think an hour and a half interview is
approximately the equivalent of a 200
page book
so we're done
why don't we why don't we end with that
and what i would like to propose is that
um we have another discussion in a
couple of months about
what you're thinking about with regards
to what you're writing now
so like we've covered the intellectual
territory we've covered the historical
territory and done a reasonable
reasonably good job i think of both
justifying
post-modernism in this discussion and
also pointing out its pitfalls and
dangers sure yes we haven't
outlined uh much
for an alternative vision except making
tangential reference to the potency of
individual capacity
but that seems to be that would seem to
be reasonable grounds for the next
discussion so
i might also be worth the next time we
chat right talking about the current
culture war issues you know one of the
things i'm very interested in is
younger people in particular right who
are in the front lines in universities
right so to speak and they're
surrounded and and uh bewildered and
angry and in some cases intimidated by
all of this microaggressions and
so forth and sometimes the
but i'm actually kind of glad that we
didn't talk about the more political end
of it today because it enabled us to
have a conversation that was almost
entirely philosophical in nature and
yeah i really think that's the right
that's the right level of analysis
because the battle that's occurring in
our culture is actually occurring at a
philosophical level i mean there's other
levels as well but that that's
that's even more important than the
political level as far as i'm concerned
well said i agree 100
nicely put all right well it was a
pleasure speaking with you it was very
much worthwhile um you have a remarkable
capacity for tracking the content of
conversations and keeping them on point
so that's quite amazing to see
because we did branch out in a lot of
different directions more or less
simultaneously and it was quite uh
helpful
in keeping the course on track that you
could so rapidly organize the you know
it was almost like you're putting a
paragraph structure in the conversation
occurred so that was something that was
really interesting to see
so anyways it was a pleasure meeting you
and thanks very much for talking with me
and all obviously
sorry go ahead i want to say much
respect for the work you're doing thanks
for having me on your show
and we're happy to talk again great good
we'll set that up all right thanks
jordan see you yeah bye-bye